[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir plus que quelques jours
avant le coup d'envoi de la coupe
d'afrique des nations pour l'occasion
nous consacrons une grande partie de
notre édition à l'événement nous irons à
yaoundé au cameroun pour prendre la
température avec notre correspondant et
nous ferons également un point sur les
équipes favorites de la compétition
et puis nous irons également au sénégal
les lions de la teranga sont souvent
favoris pour la compétition mais ils
n'ont jamais remporté la can pourquoi
cet échec notre correspondant à dakar et
limane dao a peut-être la réponse
reportage à suivre
la quatrième vague liés aux variants
ovarian omicron semble toucher à sa fin
en afrique du sud le pays est en plein
été austral les autorités sud africaines
ont levé le couvre feu mais le port du
masque est obligatoire dans l'espace
public reportage de nos correspondantes
dans quelques jours le continent tout
entier va vivre à l'heure des matches de
football les fans du ballon rond et ils
sont nombreux sont prêts à soutenir leur
équipe certains vont même faire le
déplacement et accompagner leur équipe
au cameroun où se tient la compétition
on va y aller justement retrouver notre
correspondant marcel amont comme marcel
bonsoir quelle est l'ambiance est ce que
la fièvre du football est montée
ont riposté par une fièvre qui monte
timidement on va dire lorsqu'on se
promène dans les rues de yaoundé on peut
apercevoir ses revendeurs de quêtes des
drapeaux camourenais notamment mais
aussi les drapeaux des 23 autres nations
qui vont prendre part à cette
compétition mais au niveau de
l'affichage très peu de signes visibles
qui montre que le pays s'apprête à
accueillir dans moins de 72 heures
maintenant un événement de cette
envergure au point qu'ils ont supporters
ivoiriens nous confier à tout à l'heure
qu'il ay roop mal lorsqu'il a débarqué
ici à yaoundé à imaginer que le pays de
football qu'elle cameron au pays de
roger milla et de sa mêlée tour
notamment s'apprêtait à accueillir un
événement d'une telle envergure au plus
grand événement sportif du continent
africain cinquante ans près
1972 et cette coupe d'asie des nations
qui avait laissé un goût amer au
cameroun et les camerounais
éliminé en demi-finale par le congo
brazza g d'une élimination qui avait
provoqué un véritable traumatisme
traumatisme que les supporters
camerounais espère et voire effacée par
la délégation la génération actuelle des
lions indomptables du cameroun mais pour
cela il faudra tout d'abord passer
l'obstacle du burkina faso le burkina
faso que le cameroun devra affronter en
match d'ouverture dès ce dimanche au
stade de l'aube et les burkinabè qui
sont déjà ici au cameroun en même temps
qu'une 14 n 15 autres nations donc qui
ont déjà pris leurs quartiers ici au
cameroun alors vers salon on ne peut pas
éviter la question qui fâche le stado
les mener sera-t-il prêt pour le début
du tournoi
fait depuis près de quatre ans c'est un
chantier qui a connu plusieurs comptes
ouverts plusieurs rebondissements avec
notamment un retard accumulé dans l les
travaux mais aussi des coûts exorbitants
certains observateurs ont avancé le
chiffre astronomique de 200 milliards de
francs si fort de 200 milliards de
francs cfa contre les 163 milliards qui
avait été initialement prévu pour lacan
la construction d'un complexe un
complexe qui devait abriter à la fois
une piscine olympique un centre
commercial mais aussi un hôtel cinq
étoiles on a aussi beaucoup parlé ces
derniers temps du changement de
prestataire on est passé de l'italien
qui finit au canadien magill mais au
bout du compte le stade où les b sera
prêt pour accueillir cette fête du
football africain à partir de dimanche
prochain et l'on nous allons d'ailleurs
la présence du chef de l'iec à mon
épaule bien que l'on n'a pas beaucoup vu
ces derniers temps qui lui aussi se fait
un point d'honneur
d'assister de prendre part à ce match
d'ouverture donc à cette cérémonie
d'ouverture qui a va se tenir à partir
de 17h au stade de l'aube est ici ça où
on dit et cela doit donc marquer le coup
d'envoi de cette 33e édition de la coupe
d'afrique des nations de football et on
suivra bien évidemment ça sur france 24
avec vous un marcel amont comme et aussi
avec nos équipes sur place benoît
perreault chez cédric ferreira et simone
harding armés locaux et bien d'autres
on regardera sur france 24 et on suivra
également dans le journal de l'afrique
l'évolution de cette compétition on va
s'intéresser à présent aux favoris
plusieurs pays en leurs chances d'aller
loin dans la compétition
l'egypte le cameroun où la côte d'ivoire
sans oublier bien sûr le champion en
titre l'algérie de ryad malaise revue
d'effectif signé florent au dos
selon les bookmakers ce sont eux les
favoris de cette can 2022 battu en
finale lors de la dernière édition les
sénégalais courent toujours après leur
premier trophée continental
emmené par saad you man et ballon d'or
africain en 2019
les lions de la teranga et leur
sélectionneur aliou cissé ont reçu le
drapeau national au palais présidentiel
tenant du titre l'algérie de djamel
belmadi arrive en pleine confiance au
cameroun elle peut s'appuyer sur une
série inédite pour une équipe africaine
34 matches consécutifs sans défaite des
fennecs emmenés par leur capitaine le
créatif joueur de manchester city riyad
mahrez
nation la plus titrée avec cette can à
son palmarès l'egypte elle aussi aura
son mot à dire
meilleur buteur et passeur de premier
league avec liverpool mohamed salah
marche sur l'eau depuis le début de la
saison il tentera de remporter la
première can pour son pays depuis 2010
plusieurs outsider à commencer par la
côte d'ivoire des éléphants qui comptent
dans leur rang sébastien allaire 10 buts
en seulement six matches de ligue des
champions cette saison
ne pas oublier non plus le nigeria mais
aussi le cameroun le pays hôte sacré en
2017 et qui voudra devant son public
gardez la coupe à la maison
vous l'avez entendu le sénégal fait
figure de favori c'est souvent le cas
d'ailleurs mais les lions de la teranga
n'ont jamais remporté la can ils font
bien ils sont bien arrivés en finale
c'était le cas en 2019 mais ils ne
parviennent pas à concrétiser malgré la
présence de grands talents dans leur
équipe pourquoi ces échecs notre
correspondant à dakar et limane dao a
peut-être la réponse reportage
il est la mascotte officielle de
l'équipe nationale du sénégal de
football paco à 6,7 après midi à une
séance d'entraînement des lions avec ses
compagnons dizaine d'années le célèbre
groupe de supporters du sénégal il
attend impatiemment un titre de la
sélection nationale à la coupe d'afrique
des nations
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le sénégal n'a jamais remporté la can
les lions sont souvent favoris mais
jusqu'ici jamais vainqueur pour l'ancien
international sénégalais amdy faye
finaliste malheureux à la can 2002
l'équipe nationale a du mal à aborder
les grands événements on n'a pas la
notion de la gagne et ça c'est très
important
aulas on l'a peut-être à 50% ces genres
phase finale des éliminatoires mais
aller chercher la coupe c'est ça le
problème du sénégal et ça il faut forcer
le destin c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
on met tellement l'accent sur cette
génération là après l'échec en finale
contre l'algérie lors de la précédente
édition de la can mur de la victoire
pour est en fait arrivé selon ce
journaliste sportif l'équipe peut
compter sur des joueurs de grand talent
in sélectionneur respectée dans la
colonne vertébrale de l'équipe est
composée de joueurs de classe mondiale
entre idrissa gana guèye kalidou
koulibaly edouard mendes a demandé à la
pointe dont il ya vraiment du talent
dans cette équipe là l'entraîneur
également est arrivé à un niveau où il a
acquis énormément d'expérience et sa
troisième can en tant qu'entraîneur donc
vraiment il ya beaucoup de motifs
d'espoir ça va être très difficile mais
le sénégal a les armes pour aller au
bout pour son entrée en lice à la can le
sénégal affronte le zimbabwe ce lundi il
n'y aura pas que le mental qui compte il
y aura aussi le physique et la pandémie
s'est de nouveau invitée dans la
compétition pour le moment ce sont les
deux stars de l'équipe gabonaise pierre
emerick aubameyang est ma rio les mines
à qui on fait qu'ils en ont fait les
frais ils étaient tous deux positifs au
kovy 19 à un test anti génie qu'ils
attendent le résultat d'un test pcr à
quatre jours du premier match des
panthères voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire
sur la can on passe au reste de
l'actualité alors que de nombreux pays
européens enregistrent des centaines de
milliers de cas d'eau mikron par semaine
les regards se tournent vers l'afrique
du sud c'est là-bas que le variant a été
identifiée pour la première fois
aujourd'hui le pays semble sortir de
cette quatrième vague l'iao mikron le
couvre feu est levé mais le port du
masque est obligatoire dans l'espace
public l'évolution du variant sera-t-il
similaires en europe rien n'est moins
sûr c'est ce que nous explique notre
correspondant au cap caroline vu mes
crèmes solaires et bikinis l'été austral
bat son plein sur les plages bondées du
cap où la vie paraît normal les sud
africains ne comprennent pas pourquoi le
reste du monde continue à les isoler
je pense qu'on s'en tire mieux que les
pays qui nous ferme les portes et qui
nous empêche d'aller chez eux
je crois que c'est parce que nous sommes
un pays en développement c'est pour cela
qu'ils nous ont mis sur la liste au
rouge si on était les états unis ça
n'arriverait pas
un pays en développement qui a quand
même découvert le variant au micron et
qui continue à l'étudier dans ce
laboratoire de durban on a analysé les
deux tiers des échantillons qu'ovide du
continent africain les scientifiques sud
africain ce qui sont à la pointe de la
recherche mondiale sur le col vides ont
publié plusieurs études aux conclusions
similaires le variant micron a provoqué
des formes moins grave de la maladie que
les autres variant
ce varions peut toujours rendre très
malade et peut même être mortelle mais
pour ceux qui ont une immunité qu'elles
proviennent de la vaccination ou
d'infections précédente
le risque de tomber très malade est
vraiment bas
les hôpitaux sud africains n'ont jamais
été saturé avec le vario micro les
experts pensent que la population a
développé une immunité collective lors
des vagues précédentes face à une
situation sanitaire bien maîtrisé les
autorités n'ont donc pas voulu re
confiné même s'il encourage la
vaccination 40% de la population adulte
est désormais vaccinés l'afrique du sud
à surmonter rapidement sa quatrième
vague de co vide mais l'exemple sud
africain n'est pas forcément applicable
au reste du monde car la population est
différente elle est plutôt plus jeune
que la population européenne ou
américaine elle est aussi bien immunisés
et surtout nous sommes ici au coeur de
l'été austral les températures sont bien
plus élevés qu'en europe ou aux états
unis
la rue maintient la pression contre le
pouvoir militaire au soudan de nouveaux
rassemblements se sont tenus à khartoum
la capitale trois manifestants ont été
tués selon des médecins le renverser
cher
sous une pluie de grenades lacrymogènes
la contestation se poursuit au soudan
des milliers de manifestants sont à
nouveau descendus dans les rues de
khartoum jeudi pour dire non au pouvoir
militaire
salle un pouvoir civil peut diriger le
peuple soudanais il n'y a pas d'autre
solution pour le pays vit la pire depuis
le coup d'état du 25 octobre les
manifestations se succèdent et ce malgré
une violente répression qui a déjà fait
plus de 50 morts et des centaines de
blessés un soulèvement populaire qui
dénonce la prise de pouvoir du général
abdelfattah al burhan un coup d'état
venue enrayer la transition démocratique
amorcé suite au départ du dictateur omar
el-béchir en 2019
je suis venu aujourd'hui pour demander
une vraie transition démocratique la
vérité c'est que la révolution
soudanaise n'a pas réussi à accomplir
les objectifs fixés en 2010
dimanche le premier ministrable
d'al-ahram doc annonçait sa démission
face à l'ampleur des manifestations
un temps acclamé par la rue il avait
perdu le soutien du peuple après la
signature d'un accord d'entente avec les
putschistes en novembre
le pouvoir militaire indique maintenant
vouloir le remplacer au plus vite mais
la communauté internationale met en
garde la nomination unilatérale d'un
nouveau chef du gouvernement pourrait
finir de saper la crédibilité du régime
de transition
la restitution par à la belgique de la
dent de patrice lumumba de nouveau été
reporté il s'agit du seul reste de
l'ancien premier ministre congolais le
héros de l'indépendance avait été
renversé puis exécutées par des
séparatistes de la région du katanga
avec l'appui de mercenaires de la
belgique ancienne puissance coloniale un
commissaire de police belge avait
affirmé des décennies plus tard avoir
prélevé la dent de lumumba avant que son
corps ne soit dissous dans de l'acide
cette restitution est une série
d'hommages avait déjà été reporté en
raison d'une hausse exceptionnelle des
cas de colis de 19
c'est la fin de journal de l'afrique
rester avec nous la faut continuer sur
france 24
[Musique]
chaque semaine entrez dans les coulisses
des batailles économiques au coeur de la
guerre économique ali laïdi décrypte
avec son invité les stratégies
commerciales des entreprises et des
états là où tous les coups sont permis
et l'entretien de l'intelligence
économique
présentée par ali laïdi avoir sur france
24 et sur france 24 points comme